this was not how I wanted Pride Month to
start
[Applause]
I really didn't want to talk about this
and I actually I wish that I would have
been okay with not talking about this
because it put me in a really bad way
right now but to catch people up in case
they didn't hear Gareth Roberts who is a
science fiction writer of novels and
television in the UK who has worked on
Doctor Who previously both in various
episodes of the show proper as well as
being a pretty key component to the
first few series of the Sarah Jane
Adventures had a story that he wrote for
a printed compilation of Doctor Who
stories be pulled now that this book
hasn't been released yet so that it's
being removed prior to publication and
the reason for this the the core reason
there's nuance and stuff and I know that
because I did the research on it
despite the depression it's now put me
into to do that but the core reason is
his transphobic beliefs and I honestly I
don't think I've ever actually used that
word in a video before calling anyone
anything phobic I know can be a very
loaded thing and honestly I'm kind of
already this early on I'm dreading the
comment section of this video but to
call Gareth Roberts transphobic is not
some hyperbolic it's a statement of fact
the man has made it very clear and not
like in the past
like he put out a statement giving his
side of
his story getting room be getting pulled
from this making it very clear that it
is his belief that transgender is not a
thing he does not believe in it he does
not believe that transgender people are
what they claim to be he doesn't believe
transgenderism to be real and while in
his official statement he worded that in
a more live and let live sort of we just
have a disagreement sort of way in the
past he has not spoken in that manner
now to be clear and cuz this is worth
being cleared it was something he
pointed out and from what I could find
this was accurate he has never called
for the active persecution or of trans
people or for violence against them but
he has casually used terms such as
[ __ ] which is generally accepted to be
a hate speech term towards transgender
people as well as conflating trans women
with confused gay boys
so there's a lot unpack here and I
really I really didn't want to talk
about it partly because of a few videos
from channels that I subscribed you
already have videos out on it actually
fairly well done ones Channel pub put
out one as well as mister TARDIS reviews
both of which I think are worth seeing
I'll link to them below but and honestly
if this hadn't broken during Pride Month
maybe I would have let it sit but
I couldn't I couldn't not say something
and also it is my hope that saying this
here will allow me to not have to talk
about it as I end up coming up to
reviews of episodes of Doctor Who that
he wrote as I worked my way through my
rewatch of modern era Doctor Who I've
actually already recorded reviews for a
couple of episodes of his and even
though one even though that unicorn and
the wasp hasn't been released yet at the
time this videos coming out I have
already shot it so I definitely didn't
mention it there but I'm not gonna
mention it in other videos either
because when I review the episodes I
want to review the episodes and not talk
about this so I'm talking about it here
so I don't have to talk about it later
but beyond that I don't when I saw the
conversations crop up of you know
basically people taking his side of
basically saying this is just some
difference of opinion it's it's not his
position is that a certain kind of
person doesn't exist there's no
compromise to that position if you're
trans which I am and if you're new to
the channel I'm not a trans woman I
don't claim to be I identify as gender
fluid and which gets its own thing of
people claiming it's not a thing but
what is very much the case whether you
think there's something wrong with me or
not I have certainly transitioned out of
the life of a cisgender male which I
once lived
and the claim of Gareth Roberts is that
I am not valid and aside from the fact
that that's not a position that you can
actually come to a middle ground with
it's also wrong
I'm it's demonstrably wrong at this
point in time saying that there's really
no such thing as transgender is boy I
mean I'm really gonna pile up a fun
comment section by making this
comparison but here we go anyway it is
very much the same as saying that
climate change isn't real because while
the specifics and the fine details may
not be universally agreed upon and
there's still a lot of research to be
done there is a scientific consensus
climate change is real transgenderism is
real
there's still a ton of research being
done in terms of what may or may not be
factors in causes you know from genetics
to the environment you raise and all
sorts of things and it's worth noting
that about a week ago at time of
recording the World Health Organization
voted to remove transgenderism from
being classified as a mental health
condition and they are not doing that
because of political pressure they did
that because after placing it there
because that's what they thought it was
and then having decade's worth of
studies to look at and compare and all
this research done on transgender people
they determined no we can't classify it
as a mental health issue because that is
stigmatizing and also incorrect we now
know more because we've been studying it
and so we're going to move it off
and also you know because it's real so
I'm it should be very obvious that I
wasn't going to be sympathetic to Gareth
Roberts position on this
but what has made researching it
depressing to me is people continuing to
present it as if it's just a matter of
opinion when it is as absurd to claim
that transgenderism is not real as
saying that there's no such thing as
climate change or that the earth is
really flat it is that of that same
level you are not yeah and what's
frustrating is it's always presented
like it's the rationale so I mean
obviously chromosomes don't remember
high school biology yeah I do
which is introductory stuff and I also
know that there is decade's worth of PhD
level science that has been done to
bring a heck of a lot more nuanced than
high school biology whatever bring to
any topic and but that's what makes this
depressing for me to dig into it's
seeing the prevalence of that and of
people defending him as if what he's
saying isn't absurd and hateful and I
will call it hateful because even though
again he does not call for violence or
even discrimination against trans people
by perpetuating the lie of transgenders
of not being real he is still
contributing to a movement and an
element of culture that is calling for
violence and persecution and isolation
and removal of rights from trans people
so for him to talk about that and to
make that claim which again is
is demonstrably false he doesn't have to
call for that to still be contributing
to the societal the societal elements
that are calling for that but huh this
brings us back to should he have the
it's fine it's being presented as lost
his job he didn't lose his job and
there's a couple things worth pointing
out here that again I had to pick up
through doing additional research on
this the first is the the Doctor Who
compilation is being released by BBC
books now BBC books is a subdivision of
penguin Random House not the BBC itself
so he is not being fired as an employee
of the BBC to the best of my knowledge
he's not an employee of the BBC he's a
freelance writer he's written on
commissioned jobs he's not a he's not a
staff writer with them so this deal has
actually despite the name BBC books this
actually has nothing to do with them BBC
is simply a branding on it um but it's
controlled by another company he and
he's not being fired because he was
already paid at least so far as I was
able to find if I'm wrong somebody cite
me a source but from what I could find
he was already paid for this all that's
happening is the story won't be included
with the collection it won't see
publication but he was paid for it
so nothing was stolen from him not even
the opportunity to write the story or
the opportunity to get paid for it
it's just now not gonna be seen and in
terms of how it happened this is also
worth pointing out because he made it
through his statement which I'll also
link below if you wish to read that
because I want to give you access to the
source material on this I don't want as
much as I believe I've done my homework
on this you know look at what there is
because I'm not
perfect and if I obfuscate where I'm
pulling my information from then I'm
peeing as dishonest as he is but he
presents it as if there was a social
media outrage that cost him his job at
again he didn't lose his job a piece of
his work is not gonna be published but
what actually happened was that it is
true that the fact that he had a story
that was going to be included leaked and
that led to an outcry why wasn't social
media it's actually other writers whose
stories were gonna be part of that
compilation cuz you know the various
writers assigned to it didn't know who
else was working on it didn't know who
else was contributing and there was a
collection of writers at least a few of
whom have spoken publicly and openly
about this who said that once they found
out they Gareth Roberts had a story that
was going to be included they contacted
BBC books and said if you are including
his story
do not use mine I do not want mine to be
printed alongside his and I don't have
account for how many of them there were
because not all have spoken publicly but
it was you know it was more than one and
it was that pressure along with your
usual corporate doesn't align with our
values line that you get cause like I'm
not gonna go to bat for BBC books but
that that was their explanation so there
was pressure put on but it wasn't a
social media pressure and even though a
lot of the stems from tweets he's put
out again the actual removal of his
story is because of his peers so this
isn't this is not like James Gunn where
somebody dug through his Twitter to find
years old stuff to to try and smear him
with this was his peers who
well aware of his views that just when
they heard his name they said oh wait a
minute
so ultimately people are going to know
as to whether or not I feel that was the
right thing to do and honestly I had
hoped that I would come to a firmer
conclusion on that but I don't know
because I don't I don't feel like going
to back to anybody for anybody in this
story I I will I will cop to empathizing
with Roberts to the extent of I have had
the misfortune to be in employment
situations where my views in general
were at odds with those of my employer
so I know that that's uncomfortable but
that's a very small amount of empathy
I'm prepared to give towards him because
as I said he's not actually a staff
employee at BBC books or the BBC he's a
contract
he's contract writer and so he knows who
he's taking these jobs from whenever he
takes them me when I've been in that
position and jobs I needed the job yeah
I didn't have the option of turning down
a contract I needed the work and maybe
he does - I don't mean I don't know his
financial situation but when you're
working on a contract by contract basis
you have a lot more control over who you
work for but here's what I will say had
this story broken and it was just a
matter of the
concern over his work being included was
still bubbling like if we hadn't jumped
to the end and it wasn't already decided
that his store wasn't gonna be included
I probably wouldn't personally be
calling for his dismissal or the removal
of his story I wouldn't have requested
that and I know that some people will
always you know say you got a judge the
art separate from the artists and I've
talked about that and saying I might
have to devote a fuller video to that at
some point but I had the work still been
published I wouldn't have called for the
removal of his story I wouldn't have
said that people should boycott it but I
sure as heck wouldn't have paid money
for it I wouldn't have contributed to
anyone
financially benefiting from the work of
someone who believes that I and others
like me is invalid and less than human
because think for just a second what if
he had said this about any other group
what if he'd said this about a race what
if he'd said this about a religion what
if he'd said it about women sis women
I'm not gonna say no we'll be jumping to
his defense but far fewer would it would
just be the far right people who say you
should never apologize who would be
jumping to his defense instead of a lot
of middle ground people who are going
out just live and let live
because when your position is that a
certain kind of person doesn't exist
that's not live-and-let-live you're
denying personhood you're denying
validity and again there was a
scientific consensus that transgenderism
is real is quantifiable and is not a
mental disorder and it just it leaves me
in a bad place to have it reaffirmed
because I know this but that Tran the
transgender communities the current
acceptable punching bag five years ago
the gay community still was which is
frustrating because Gareth Edwards is
are not Gareth Edwards Gareth Roberts I
might have said that earlier - I'm
really been paranoid about that Gareth
Roberts himself is gay so he should have
a perspective for knowing what it's like
to be told no that's not real you're
making a choice that's not a fact of you
that's something you're choosing to do
being thrust in at him and used to
invalidate him because like I said five
years ago it was gay people and before
that it was non-white races said to just
be just naturally biologically inferior
and you go back far enough not even
necessarily human and I know that trans
people are the acceptable group
currently to be making these arguments
with because most conservative these off
days after my release in the u.s. after
gay marriage became the law of the land
so now it's me and people like me and I
don't have a final point I just needed
to talk about this because not talking
about it felt wrong and I'm not looking
forward to the comments on this those
are my thoughts about it if you're still
here and you have thoughts to share you
can do it respectfully drop something
down in the comments
and let's try and talk about it there's
other stuff to do it as well this
patreon to support this channel you can
like subscribe and all of it helps but
you also don't have to do any of it
because at the end of the day folks
you're beautiful you're love you are
valid
you are the council I just run the
meetings so until next time this council
is adjourned
and I'm going to I'm gonna watch Shira
and pet myself up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]